[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى ملفات الخامسه من
العربيه والبدايه في ابرز عناوينها
في محاوله الاحتواء الاحتجاجات رئيسيه
يجتهدوا دستوريا والادعاء العام الايراني
ضبط الحدود المشتركه مع ايران وتركيا
ويعزز قوات حرس الحدود
توتر امنيه تجدد في السويداء قتيل وجرحى
برصاص الامن بعد اقتحام محتاجين مبنى
المحافظه
من ملفات الخامسه نتو يستعد لحرب سيبرانيه
وتهامه لروسيا بتنسيقها هجماتها
الالكترونيه والمدفعيه باوكرانيا
اهلا بكم بدايه الخامسه من ايران وفي
محاوله لتهدئه الاحتجاجات المتواصله في
البلاد وفشل النظام في اخمادها حتى الان
اعلن الموضوع العام الايراني الغاء ما
تعرب شرطه الاخلاق في محاوله لتهدئه
المتظاهرين وكانت هذه القوه احد اهم اسباب
التظاهرات التي اندلعت في السادس عشر من
سبتمبر الماضي بعد مقتل الفتاه محسن
البالغه من العمر 22 عاما خلال احتجازيها
من قبل وحده تابعه لما يسمى بشرطه الاخلاق
[موسيقى]
هذا هو كشفت مصادر المطلعه على العربيه
وشهود عيان عن عدم تعرض اجهزه الامن
الايراني الى النساء اللواتي لا يرتدين
الحجاب بالشكل الذي يفرده النظام منذ عقود
فيما قال نشيطون وحقوقيون ان الاحتجاجات
المشتعله في البلاد منذ اكثر من شهرين
اجبرت النظام الايرانيه على التراجع من
جانبه اعلن المدعي العام محمد جعفر منتظري
ان البرلمان والسلطه القضائيه يعملان على
مراجعه قانون الحجاب وان النتائج ستصدر في
غضون اسبوع او اسبوعين
[تصفيق]
ينضم الينا من امستردام الصحفي المتخصص في
شان الايرانيه يعقوب سعيد مرحبا بك سيد
يعقوب لنقل بدايه حول قراءتك للقرار الخاص
بحل شرطه الاخلاق وبتصريحات رئيسي حول
الدستور البعض فهم من هذه التصريحات او
اثرت حاله من الجدل هل يعلن رئيسي بذلك عن
امكانيه تعديل الدستور ام تطبيق الدستور
بشكل مختلف هناك حاله من الجده حول هذه
التصريحات
طيبه لك قناه العربيه بالتاكيد يعني علينا
ان نعرف بان قبل هذه الشرطه سبقتها الكثير
من الدوريات التي تاسست خلال الثمانينات
والتسعينات القرن الماضي في ايران وكانت
تقوم بنفس المهمه هي مراقبه الحجاب في
ايران هذه الشرطه هي اساسا جديده وبالتالي
الغاءها لا يعني
بداخل ايران ممكن همم نتيجه الضغوط التي
على المستوى الداخلي وعلى المستوى الخارجي
قرروا الغاء هذه الشرطه ولكن هناك الكثير
من ال- ال- يعني ال- ال- لديك الشرطه
والبسيج والحرس الثوري وكذلك الامن
الداخلي يقومون بنفس مهام شرطه الاخلاق
اذا شرطه الاخلاق قتلت
فالوريات الاخرى هي قتلت اكثر 470 محتج في
ايران بينهم اطفال حتى هذه اللحظه فيما
يتعلق بالدستور يعني ايضا ممكن اضيف شيء
واحد يمكن قراءه هذا الجانب على انهتصاص
الغضب الجماهير داخل ايران وحاله انه
تقديم تنازلات الشكليه بالنسبه للمحتاجين
لا اتصور هذا ينعكس على الشارع لانه
الشارع يعرف تماما بانه النظام الايراني
لا يمكن ان يقدم اصلاحات بالحوار وبالتالي
هو يكذب حتى يثبت العكس هذه
الذي كان يقصده رئيسي تحديدا حين حدث في
مساله الدستور لان التصريح بالفارسيه
وترجم للانجليزيه ومنها الى العربيه
وبالتالي هناك حاله من الخلط في مساله هذا
التصريح تحديدا ما الذي يعنيه
وتصور بانه هم يقصدون بحاله من يعني هو
همم امتداد لالغاء شرطه الاخلاق وبالتالي
تخفيف هذه الرقابه على مساله الحجاب ولكن
التعديلات الدستوريه داخل ايران دائما تجد
همم جدار كبير وهو همم ولايه الفقير في اي
تعديل دستوري لا يمص بصلاحيات ولايه
الفقيه في ايران هي تعديلات شكليه وهي
حصلت في الثمانينات القرن الماضي خامنئي
او بتعبير اداء منصب ولايه الفقيه يتخلخل
في جميع السلطات داخل ايران السلطه
القضائيه والسلطه التنفيذيه والسلطه
التشريعيه داخل ايران وبالتالي هذه
الصلاحياته ايضا على المستوى الدستوري لا
يمكن تغييرها الا بظهور الامام المهدي
الغائب في المذهب الشيعي فلذلك لا رئيس
ولا غير رئيسي ولا حتى استفتاء شعبي يمكن
ان يغير من صلاحيات خامنئي هذا من جانب
اما فيما يتعلق بحاله الحجاب لا اتصور
ايضا هم يقومون بحاله الغاء الزاميه
الحجاب داخل ايران لانه هذا يصطدم بجدار
79 بعد الثوره هو يحمل مواد تبدو امم يعني
تتحدث عن الحقوق والحريات والقوميات بشكل
منفتح للغايه بالطبع لانه جاء بعد ثوره
ولكن السؤال الان هل ما حدث من تصريحات
لرئيس تشير الى ثم التغيير يمكن ان يحدث
في القوانين التي يجب ان تستلهم روح هذا
الدستور ام ماذا
لا اتصور ذلك يعني وحتى ان حدثت فهي ستحدث
على المستوى الشكلي لان الدستور الايراني
مثلا يذكر هو الغاء الاستبداديه والدكتور
الديكتاتوريه في البلاد بينما الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه في عام عندما تاسست يتاسست على
اساس ديكتاتوري وعلى اساس استبدادي وعلى
اساس الحكم الواحد عندما الغي جميع
الاحزاب وبقوا حزب همم الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه في ايران فلذلك اي تغييرات سوف
تحدث في المستقبل وانا استبعدها كذلك سوف
تكون تغييرات شكليه فقط في محاوله
الانتقاليه هل رئيسي المحل هذا الامر ام
لا المحا لمساله تغيير الدستور ام لا
لا لا هو لم يلمح اساسا لتغيير دستوري هو
قال بان الدستور اي اي على المستوى
الداخلي ليس جامد على المستوى الايراني
فبالتالي لم يلمح يعني لم يقلها صراحه
بانهم سوف يقومون بتغيير دستوري داخل على
المستوى الايراني ولا يعني هذا الشيء لم
يذكره ابدا هذا ما تم ترجمته الى لغات عده
كما تفضلت قبل قليل ولكن الانجليزيه
والعربيه بشكل مختلف فتح الباب لفكره
المرونه في تغيير الدستور كما تصورها لبعض
لكن النصب الفارسيه كما تقول انت الان لا
يشير الى هذا الامر لا لا ابدا لم يشر
صراحه الى الى رد داخليه وحتى لو يعني
بالمستقبل انا لا استبعد بينهم سوف
يتحدثون بالمستقبل عن تغييرات لانه هذه
الاصوات ليس جديده طبعا رئيس لم يقل ذلك
همم اكرر ذلك ولكن حتى لو في المستقبل
قالها فذلك لن يتحقق على المستوى الداخلي
وانت تحقق سوف يكون تحقيق شكل فقط اشكرك
من امستردام الصحفي المتخصص في شان
الايراني يعقوب سعيد تحياتي
هذا هو اعتبرت انشطه الايرانيه مسيح علي
نجاد قرار النظام الايراني حل شرطه
الاخلاق تكتيكيا لوقف صعود الانتفاضه
وقالت في تغريده لها على تويتر مع نشر
مقاطع مصوره للتعدي على النساء في الشوارع
قالت ان الايرانيين لم يواجهوا البنادق
والرصاص لاسقاط شرطه الاخلاق وانما لاسقاط
النظام
[موسيقى]
منظمه العفو الدوليه بدورها افادت بانها
28 ايرانيه على الاقل يواجهون خطر الاعدام
بينهم ثلاثه اطفال واشارت المنظمه الى انه
حتى الان حكم على سته متظاهرين على الاقل
بالاعدام في محاكمه سوريه واتهمت العفو
الدوليه النظام الايراني باستخدام عقوبه
الاعدام كاداه للقمه السياسيه لخلق الرعب
ومحاوله انهاء الانتفاضه الشعبيه
ومع تواصل الاحتجاجات في ايران برزت اسماء
ضحايا قمع النظام مساء اميني اول ضحايا
الاحتجاجات الحاليه ولكنها ليست الاخيره
حيث تكررت ماساه امينه مره ثانيه ولكن
باسماء مختلفه ابرزها نغني عبد المالكي
الطالبه التي تعرضت لضرب مبرح بالحروات
على الراس من قبل قوات الامن ما تسبب لها
بنزيف داخلي ادى الى وفاتها تكرر المشهد
مره اخرى مع الطالبه اسرى بناهي ذات ال 15
ربيعا والتي هاجمتها قوه الامن في مدرسه
شمال غرب ايران ضمن مجموعه من الطالبات
المتظاهرات لينتهي الامر بمقتلها سبقتها
نكهه رامي ذات السته عشر عاما نكيا فقدت
او فقدت في طهران في 20 من سبتمبر بعد ان
اخبرت صديقه لها ان الشرطه تط ليتبين انها
كانت بين يدي الحركه الدوليه الايرانيه
وتنتهي حياتها في ظروف غامضه ويعفر بعد
ذلك على جثتها ملقا في طريقه الهراوات
ذاتها قتلت سارينا المراهقه والتي كانت
تنشط على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الروايه
الحكوميه ذاتها تتكرر وتنكر اي تورط
لسلطات في مقتل الفتيات المراهقات مدعيه
انهن انتحرنا او قتلنا في ظروف غير معروفه
تلك كانت اسماء بعض من رحع ضحيه قمع
النظام لكن ارقام الضحايا اكثر بكثير فقد
تجاوزت 460 شخصا حسب منظمات حقوقيه
[موسيقى]
والمتابعه هذا الملف حقوقيا ينضم الينا من
اصله عضو منظمه حقوق الانسان الاحوزيه
عمار تسائي مرحبا بك سيد عمار هذه الحالات
التي تم توثيقها بشكل واضح من قبل منظمات
حقوق الانسان هل يمكن ان تؤدي الى انشاء
تحقيق دولي محايد وشفاف حول الانتهاكات
التي وقعت في ايران ومن هو الطرف القادر
على تحقيق هذا الامر
تحيه لك وللمشاهدين الكرام بطبيعه الحال
هذه هذه الامر هو بدا فعليا عندما
قام باصدار قرار مجلس حقوق الانسان للامم
المتحده
وتم تشكيل لجنه تقصي الحقائق وسوف يبدا
عمل هذه اللجنه قريبا وسوف تقوم هذه
الاجنه بجمع الوثائق والتوثيق حالات
انتهاء حقوق الانسان ومن ثم الاشخاص
المتورطين وسوف
تتعاون مع هذه المنظمه الجهات الدوليه
حقوقيه كثيره وسوف يتم التعرف على اسماء
منتهي في حقوق الانسان والمسؤولين الذين
اصدروا مثل هذه الاوامر هذه تشكيل لجنه من
قبل مجلس حقوق الانسان التابع للامم
المتحده باعتبار ان هذا الاجراء سيصل الى
صفه دوليه ها في هذا التحقيق وليس عمل
اهلي او خاص
بجمع الوثائق ورصد الوثائق وحتى ربما
الاتصال بذوي وعوائل او الشهود الذين
شهدوا بعض حالات انتهاك حقوق الانسان سواء
في السجون او في الشوارع ومن ثم ترفع هذا
الملف الى مجلس الامن او الى جهات حقوقيه
وحتى ربما يصل الامر الى المحاكم الدوليه
وربما سوف تصدر قرارات من هذه المحاكم ضد
المسؤولين الايرانيين او ضد اولئك
العسكريين
والشرطه قاعده الشرطه همم تصدر ربما احكام
للاعتقال
ومحاكمتهم في المحاكم الدوليه كما حصل
جرت العاده ان هذه التحقيقات تاخذ وقتا
طويلا لا يتم من نظر اليها والى نتائجها
بشكل كبير يعني اذا تذكر قضيه الاعدامات
الشهيره بعد كم عام تم النظر في هذه
القضيه والتي اتهم فيها رئيس نفسه
في ذلك الوقت لم يكن هناك التكنولوجيا لم
تكن متطوره مثل الان ولم ااه لم يتم توثيق
هذه كما انه النظام كان قبضه امنيه شديده
ومع ذلك تم يعني تم همم التعرف على اولئك
الاشخاص رغم انه مرور بعد مرور ما يقارب
30 عام ولكن تم التعرف على هؤلاء وامل ان
لا يفوت من قبضه العداله سواء العداله
التي يحققها همم الايرانيون او تلك التي
همم من محاكم الدوليه لان تلك كانت جريمه
ولكن ما نشهده الفرق ما نشهده اليوم ان
الاحداث متسارعه والنظام في حاله ارت
وايضا عامل نظيفه وتهكير او القرصنه
المعلومات التي يتبادلها قاده النظام
والرؤساء النظام هذه ايضا ربما تكون وثائق
دامقه تقدم الى محاكم المحاكم الدوليه في
الوضع مختلف تماما اما بالنسبه الوقت التي
سوف يستغرقه هذا الامر
حقوق هذا يستغرق وقتا ربما طويلا كما
تفضلت ولكن بالنهايه اعتقد انه سوف يؤثر
ويؤثرها ايضا على معنويات المتظاهرين
بانهم يشعرون ليسوا وحدهم هناك من يطالب
بحقهم وهناك من يدافع من انسانيتهم
وكرامتهم واحتفظ هذا عامل مهم ودافع مهم
لل- المتظاهرين لمواصلات المظاهرات
والدفاع
نعم من اصله عضو منظمه حقوق الانسان
للاحوزيه عمار تسائي شكرا لك سيد عمار
ونبقى معكم في سياق الخامسه من العربيه
ولدينا
مشاهد مصوره تظهر حجم الدمار الذي لحق
بمدينه
شرقا اوكرانيا
الى اخبار كاس العالم في الدوحه القطريه
حيث تواجه فرنسا اليوم بولندا فيما تقابل
انجلترا منتخب السنغال في دور 16 وكانت
الارجنتين تجاوزت امس استراليا بهدفين
لهدف ضاربه موعد مع هولندا الفائزه على
المنتخب الامريكي بثلاثه اهداف لهدف واحد
ومن قلب الحدث من الدوحه مو فاضي العربيه
ليس بزاري مرحبا بك ليث مواجهه صعبه وخاصه
ان الدور 16 اما ان تكون داخل اللعبه او
تغادر بطائره الى خارج الدوحه كيف تبدو
الاجواء لديك قبل مباراه فرنسا وبولندا
ولكن نعم هنا الاجواء يعني احتفالات كبيره
امبارح كنا بمباراه الارجنتين واسواره
رائعه ولكن اليوم كما نشاهد هذا الشخص اجى
من اليوم مدينه اليوم في فرنسا الديك
الفرنسي شعار فرنسا والاجواء عن جد يعني
مولعه مثل ما بنقول يلا يلا يلا
جاء وصل امبارح على الدوحه وكان اخر طائره
اييه انتقلت يوم امس من باريس الى الى
الدوحه وكان علامه هذه الطائره وهو صوبتكم
حتى النهائي وان شاء الله فرنسا تكون في
نهائي كاس العالم
نعم هذا الديك الفرنسي هذا الديك لك
فرنسيه
شعار فرنسي
[موسيقى]
من الفرنسيه
قد يحمل لهم بعض المفاجات غير ساره بماذا
يشعرون
عربي
المباراه او تربح كاس العالم
[موسيقى]
بابي
[تصفيق]
فرنسي
الشاب الذي شاهدنا قبل قليل قال ان الفريق
قوي و سوف يربحون هذه المباراه وهم طبعا
من مشجعين والمحبين طبعا مبابي الذي الذي
يقوم
بالكثير من المفاجات المباريات عندما يسجل
اهداف غريبه وطريفه احيانا ولكن هذه اجواء
الاجواء الحماسيه خارج الملعب ما بعرف
ادعي لنا وقت رشا بس ممكن نروحها وتشوف
كمان مشجعين
نعم نعم
هناك مشجعين هناك موسيقى في هذه المنطقه
لا استطيع الاقتراب حتى نسمع الصوت
وائل الفرنسيين وينك هولنديين لازم نتجه
حتى البوابه هناك فرنسيون لا
لا جمهور من بولندا
[موسيقى]
نعم كثير من فرنسا
محبين المنتخب
كاس العالم والمباراه القادمه
نعود الى ملفات الخمسه اعلنا الجيش
العراقي بدا تنفيذ اجراءات ضبط الحدود مع
كل من ايران وتركيا وقال الناطق باسم
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه العراقيه
اللواء يحيى الرسول في مؤتمر انه تم تعزيز
قوات حرس الحدود والمخافر الحدوديه
بالاسلحه والمعدات والافراد لضمان القيام
بمهامتها بشكل جيد وشد الرسول على ان
العراق يرفض استخدام اراضيه لتهديد دول
وينضم الينا من بغداد مراسله عربيه سامر
الكبيسي مرحبا بك سامر يبدو اننا امام
اجراء جديد وربما متطور في حجم التصدي لي
الهجمات التركيه والايرانيه على اقليم
كردستان دعنا في كواليس اتخاذ هذا القرار
وماء ستسفر عنه او يسفر عنه من خطوات فيما
يتعلق بتعزيز التسلح في هذه الحدود
العراقيه تعلن عن تعزيزات امنيه على
الحدود او على شريط الحدود بين العراق
وايران وبين تركيا والعراق ايضا لكن على
ما يبدو ان التركيز فقط او بشكل اكبر على
الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه خاصه بعد
الزياره لرئيس الوزراء محمد السوداني الى
طهران وكان ربما من اهم الملفات التي طرحت
على الطاوله وكان الحديث بها بشكل مباشر
هو الاعتداءات التي تقوم بها ايران على
همم اقليم كردستان كذلك التسلل بحسب طبعا
ما تعلن ايران التسلل من قبل همم المعارضه
الايرانيه المسلحه من اقليم كردستان
باتجاه ايران على اثر ذلك كان هناك همم
مجموعه من الاجتماعات لرئيس الوزاره مع
القيادات الامنيه بالتالي اصبح فعليا
اليوم همم الانتشار الامني لقياده قوات
حرس الحدود يساندها طبعا البيشمركه وكذلك
اا الجيش العراقي اضافه الى زياده عدد
المخاطر طبعا على الجانب الاخر رشا يعني
القوات الايرانيه انتشرت ايضا بشكل قريب
جدا من الحدود العراقيه اليوم اللواء يحيى
رسول اكد على ان هناك تنسيق بين الجانبين
لمنع اي تسلل من العراق باتجاه ايران
وكذلك العراق يرفض اي اعتداءات من قبل
اجانب الايراني او حتى التركي على الاراضي
العراقيه تحديدا في اقليم كردستان ربما
هذه كانت الرساله من الحكومه العراقيه الى
كل من ايران وتركيا بانها جاده في ضبط
الحدود لكن هذا الموضوع هو الموضوع شائك
جدا يمتد طبعا من ثمانيات القرن الماضي
وصولا الى هذه اللحظه ولكن نحن امام تدخل
من الحكومه المركزيه الان في بغداد
للتعامل مع هذه التهديدات في اقليم
كردستان بهذه تعزيزات على الحدود زميلي
سامر القبيسي مراسله العربيه من بغداد
شكرا لك
تحدث المرصد السوريه عن مقتل شخص واصابه
سته برصاص قوات الامن خلال احتجاجات في
السويداء وكان الاعلام السوريه الرسميه
وسط المحتاجين في السويداء بانه مجموعه من
الهاربين من العداله وقال انهم احرقوا
وثائق رسميه وتشهد مدينه السويداء جنوب
سوريا توتر امنيا كبيرا بعد اقتحام
المحتاجين مبنى الحكومي واحراق سياره
امنيه وحسب جهود ايام دخلت القوه الامنيه
بين جموع المتظاهرين واطلقوا الرصاصه
لتفريق المحتاجين في مدينه السويداء واشار
المرصد السوري الى مئات المواطنين في
السويداء
على تدهور الاوضاع المعيشيه وعدم تامين
حكومه النظام مستلزمات الحياه الاساسيه في
المدينه
وانضم الينا رامي عبد الرحمن مدير المرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان مرحبا بك سيد رامي
دعنا في اخر التطورات فيما يتعلق بتضاهرات
السويداء الباديه يقول ان هذه احتجاجات
نتيجه الغلاء وارتفاع اسعار المعيشه
وصعوبه المعيشه ايضا وان هناك تعامل عنيف
من قبل قوات الامن
احتجاجيه على تردد الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
وكان من المفترض ان يخرج فيها العشرات
واذا بهذا تحول الى مئات خرجوا في هذه
المظاهرات بالنسبه لي الوضع الان هناك
دخول لقوات النظام وانتشار في المدينه
ويعني انتفاء المتظاهرين كي لا يكون هناك
شباك مع قوات النظام التي انتشرت في
المدينه هناك شرطه ايضا قتل همم نتيجه
اطلاق رصاص عند اقتحام من مبنى المحافظه
هناك شهيد مدني همم قتل برصاص قوات النظام
هناك سته جرحه احدهم بحاله حرجه قد يكون
فارق الحياه وهذا البلد من هو همم وايضا
جرح اخرين ايضا يعني محاوله قوات النظام
التظاهره همم لم تتمكن نتيجه الغدر من قبل
السكان الذين هم همم يعني متظاهرين
مطلبيين وليسوا مس وهاربين من العداله كان
يوجد فيهم ملاعه علاقه له
برجنائيه ولا غير جنائيه لا نعلم اذا
النظام ما قام بالافلاه او الافراج عن بعض
المطلوبين للعداله بين مزدوجين كي يقول
بانها هناك متظاهرين مطلوبين العداله لكن
بالنهايه تمكن هؤلاء المتظاهرين من اسقاط
صوره بشار الاسد وهو رمز للاصابه في تلك
المنطقه ووقعها مبنى المحافظه في رساله
موجهه للمحافظه الذي وعد الابناء ابناء
السويداء بانه سيؤمن لهم يعني الوقود
سيؤمن لهم اقل ما يكون من مقومات استمرار
الحياه وهو فشلها في ذلك لذلك قام
المتظاهرون باقتحام هذا الرمز مبنى
المحافظه التي يمثل حكومه النظام في هذه
المحافظه التي
تتحدث فيها الان على الهواء
لا لا ما علي يعني هناك المتظاهرين لا
يعني لم يطلب النظام هو فرض سيطرته بالعكس
المتظاهرين كفؤوا كي لا يكون هناك مزيد من
الدماء من ابناء السويداء الذين حق اللحظه
هناك شهيد مدني وايضا هناك شرطي قتل وهناك
مدني اخر من المتظاهرين
بحرجه
قبل ذلك قبل ان تدخل القوات النظام قام
المتظاهرين بقطع طريق السويداء دمشق
وعندما تكون المظاهره والثوره هي مطلبيه
لا تقوم حقيقه الامر بالاستمرار هي وجهت
رساله والرساله وصلت ليس فقط للمحافظه
السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن
تحياتي
ومعنا في الخامسه في تطورات الحرب في
اوكرانيا شاهدت محمود دمار نهائي لا رجلك
في الوقت الذي تشهد المدينه محاولات روسيه
لسيطره عليها في ذلك فيما اعلنت القوات
الموليه لروسيا في اوكرانيا مقتل خمسه
مدنيين بسبب قصف اوكرانيه على دونسك
وفي سياق الحرب ايضا شهدت عاصمه السونيا
اجتماع 150 خبيرا بالامن السيبراني في حلف
شمال الاطلسي النيتو استعدادا لحرب
الالكترونيه متوقعه ذات ذلك في وقت حضرت
فيه شركه مايكروسوفت من ان روسيا تلصق
الهجمات الالكترونيه على البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه الاوكرانيه بضربات صاروخيه
تحتيه في اوكرانيا لا تحقق الهدف المرجوع
لروسيا بشكل تام
لتمارسها هجمات من نوع اخر حرب
التقليديه تستخدم فيها الهجمه الالكترونيه
لنفس التاثير المدمر للصواريخ والقذائف
صراع العصر الجديد
الى ابواب خطيره تفتحها الحرب السيبانيه
على دول العالم عموما واعضاء الحلف خصوصا
والتي تقدم الدعم العسكريه والانسانيه
لكيف ما كان من اكبر حلف عسكري الا ان
يدعم تدريباته العسكريه بتدريبات
سايبرانيه
تحاكلها هجمات المتوقعه التي قد تشنها
روسيا بشكل مكثف على اوكرانيا ودول الجوار
الداعمه لها بهدف وقف الخدمات الحيويه
مئه وخمسون خبيره امني سيبراني من 40 دوله
ومنظمه اجتمعت في تالين العاصمه الاستونيه
لخوض تدريبات التحالف السيبيراني 22
بغرض الرد على الهجمات على شبكات الطاقه
والسفن وغيرها اظهرت هذه العمليه توسيع
الاسره الالكترونيه التي تتصدى للهجمات
السيبرانيه خارج الاطار العسكري ونحن
نحتاج الى التدريب على كيفيه التعاون في
هذا المجال
مخاوف عززها عملاق التكنولوجيا مايكروسوفت
من خلال تقرير يتهم فيه الحكومه الروسيه
بتنسيق ضربات سيبرانيه على اوكرانيا
الشركه زعمت انا موسكو لن تؤطر تلك
الهجمات في اوكرانيا فقط بل ستضرب سلاسل
الامداد العسكريه والانسانيه لدول الجوار
ما يسهل الهجمه المستقبليه
نظرا لدخول موسم الشتاء وصعوبات تنفيذ
الهجمات الماديه قد لا تتمتع الفتره
القادمه بالهدوء المتوقع بل تشتعل الحرب
من خلف الشاشات لا من خلف المدفعيات
وتنضم الينا من مصر والمخصصه في شؤون
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه الروسيه الينا
سبولينا مرحبا بك الينا معنا على شاشه
العربيه نحن امام التقارير تشير الى ان
روسيا ستبدا موجه كبيره من الحرب سيبرانيه
انصح تعبير للتعامل مع ما يبدو من جمود
نتيجه وقف العمليات العسكريه او صعوبتها
في الشتاء الى اي مدى هذه التقارير دقيقه
من وجهه النظر الروسيه
اكيد غير دقيقه وانا منذ يومين قد حضرت
مؤتمر الدول مكافحه الارهاب
والهجمات السيبيريانيه وكان هذا المؤتمر
في موسكو وكانوا حاضرين رؤساء شركات
سبريانيه كثيره مثلا شركه
وغيرهم بالعكس وصف الحاله هذه كمعاكس
تماما ان هناك
سبدريانيه من قبل الدول الغرب من قبل
قراصنه وراء استخبارات غربيه ومؤسسات
الدوله الروسيه يوميا تتعرض له هجومات
بالاضافه
من قبل اوكراني
ونحن في حاله المواجهه العسكريه معها
فهذيك له هجومات من قبل اوكرانيا الان
زادت بشكل كبير
نعم الينا نحن في حرب وبالتالي كلا
الطرفين يوجه الاتهامات للطرف الاخر ولكن
من الناحيه العمليه فيما يتعلق بمصار هذه
الحرب ماذا ترين هل ما يحدث يشير الى
اتساع احمد العمليات العسكريه في هذه
الحرب ام انها تم التحول يمكن ان يحدث في
نقطه المفاوضات
والله حتى بيعادي في النقطه اسمحيلي انا
اختلف معكم ما انتم قلتم انه هناك حاله من
الجنود الان بسبب موسم الشتاء ولكن هناك
بعض الخبراء العسكريين في روسيا يعتقدون
انه بالعكس بعد
يتجنب يتجمد التراب في اوكرانيا هذا ممكن
ان يسهل العمليات عسكريه
ومرور معدات ثقيله في وقت الخريف في موسم
الخليفه هذا كان صعب في نهايته الان هناك
ثلج هناك
الحراره تحت الصفر وهذا ممكن ان يسهل مرور
دبابات ومدرعات هذا يعني انه اذا بعد همم
القوات الروسيه ان تقوم بهجومات مضاده
فعليها ان تفعل هذا الشيء الان في الشتاء
او هذا
فصل الشتاء هو يوجه صعوبه ليها
الاوكرانيين وليس للروسي ولكن بماذا
تفسرين تراجع اعداء القوات العسكريه
الروسيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه خلال
الفتره الماضيه هناك تقارير تشير الى هذا
الامر
بعد التقارير الاوكرانيه تشير همم كانهم
يتقدمون ولكن همم اليوم اتانا خبر مثلا من
منطقه في شرق اوكرانيا
والقوات وزاره الدفاع الروسيه قد قال انه
هناك تقدم للقوات الروسيه في هذه المنطقه
بالذات
سحبت من مدينه هيرسون على نهر
وهنا كانت وما زالت همم الانتقادات في
داخل روسيا في سبب هذا الانس
نعم هناك اتصالات دبلوماسيه تحت الطاوله
ما بين روسيا وامريكا حول ايجاد حلول
سياسيه في اوكرانيا ولكن في نفس الوقت حسب
ما اعرف ما زال هناك التحضير لهجوم المضاد
من قبل روسيا في شرق اوكرانيا وجنوب
اوكرانيا
الدخول في المفاوضات انه غير مستعد وفقا
لتصريحات وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه بلانكن
هو بوتين يتحدث عن مفاوضات بدون اي شروط
هكذا نفهم
نعم يتحدث حول المفاوضات بدون اي شروط
ولكن هناك شروط تعجيزيه من قبل اوكرانيا
ومن قبل امريكا حسب كلام بيده انه هذه
الشروط التعجيزيه هي تتطلب الانسحاب
الروسي من الاقاليم الاربعه في شرق
اوكرانيا ومن شبه جزيره القرم حتى وهذا
الشيء مستحيل
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه الروسيه من موسكو
تحياتي
اكد نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه الكسندر
نوفاك ان روسيا لن تتعامل بموجب سقف اسعار
النفط حتى اذا اضطرت الى خفض الانتاج
واضاف نوفاك ان روسيا تعمل على وضع اليات
لحظر الامدادات التي يتم تحديده سقف ساري
لها واشار الى ان سقف الاسعار قد يؤثر على
دول اخرى ايضا
والخامسه مستمره معكم من العربيه ولدينا
عوده وثلاثه رواد فضاء صينيين بعد اتمام
مهامه استمرت سته اشهر في الفضاء
اهلا بكم من جديد نذكر فطار فقط بيعوج
العربيه منذ قليل وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه
تهم واشنطن بدعم الاحتياجات للتاثير على
طيران في الملف النووي الايراني في الملف
اليمنيه اكد وزير الخارجيه الايطاليه على
اهميه تمديد الهدنه في اليمن واستئناف
المفاوضات الشامله لانهاء الصراع جاء ذلك
خلال لقاء الوزير الايطالي بنظره اليمني
احمد عوض بمبارك وذلك على هامشي منتدى
حوارات روما المتوسطيه وقالت وكاله
الانباء اليمنيه ان بمبارك تطرق الى ما
يتعرض له الشعب اليمني من اعتداءات
الحوثيه متكرره مستهدفه الاعيان المدنيه
والمنشات النفسيه وموانئ تصدير النفط
مشيرا الى قرار تصنيفيا الحوثي منظمه
ارهابيه
رافقت كاميرا العربيه فرقه تابعه للاصول
الخامس اثناء عمليه لنشر مسيرات بحريه في
المياه الدوليه بالخليج العربي
المصيرات على ثلاثه انواع منها التي تطوف
فوق الماء ومنها التي تغوص تحت سطحه اضافه
الى زوارق سريعه بدون قبطان متابعه تفاصيل
مع زميل بديع يونس
العسكري الافقي الرقم
15 جهاز متطوره 13 منهم بدون طيار او
قبطان وعشره بينهم لم يستخدموا سابقا وحصل
عليهم الاسطول الخامس لاول مره
لا يمكن لهذه السفينه الحربيه الاقتراب من
المسيرات لدواعي انها تقوم بالتشويش عليها
لذا سوف ناخذ هذا الزورق للاقتراب من
المصيرات قدر المستطاع تعالوا معنا في هذه
الجوله
[موسيقى]
نرى في هذه الرحله ثلاثه انواع من
المسيرات المسيره الاولى التي شاهدناها
يمكن ان تنزل تحت الماء نرى هذه المسيره
ايضا ولكنها تطوف على وجه الماء
ونتوجه الان لرؤيه الزوارق المسيره والتي
هي النوى الثالث من المسيرات المنتشره هنا
في مياه الخليج العربي
هذا هو ثالث الانواع من الزوارق المسيره
والتي تنتشر هنا في مياه الخليج العربي
[موسيقى]
من الخليج العربي بديع يونس العربيه
الى السودان
لمجلس السياده بان نائب رئيس المجلس محمد
حمدان دبلوم اكد اهميه التواصل للتفاقه
النهائيه بين السودان ومصر واثيوبيا بشان
سد النهضه وذلك لضمان حقوق الجميع
المفاوض حول اسد النهضه اطلع على سير
المحادثات واخر التطورات حول الملف وشدد
على ضروره ان يكون الحوار والتوافق مرتكزا
اساسيا لمعالجه ملف سد النهضه بما يمكن
الدول الثلاثه من الاستفاده منه وعدم
تضررها
ومن السودان الى اثيوبيا فقط قال قائد
قوات التمرد في تجري ان المتمردين سحبوا
نحو 65% من مقاتلهم من خطوط الجبهه وذلك
بعد شهر من اتفاق وقت اطلاق النار واكد
قائد قوات التمرد بدا نقل القوات من خطوط
القتال الى اماكن اخرى محدده خارجه الجبهه
وننتقل الان الى المجاز الرياضي واللقاءات
المرتقبه اليوم وهي لقاء ساخنه بالطبع
التفاصيل مع زميلي محمد الجنه
[موسيقى]
شكرا جزيلا رشا بالتاكيد ليله ساخنه في
المونديال ولذلك لا تكون باخباري حياكم
الله خلال المباراه الالف في مسيرته قد
ليونيل ميسي منتخب الارجنتين بلوغي ربع
نهائي كاس العالم على حساب استراليا ضارب
موعد
نهائي نتيجه المنتخب
الخامسه
يسجل الهدف الثاني للمنتخب الارجنتيني لكن
منتخب استراليا لم يرمي المنديل وتمكن في
الدقيقه في السابعه والسبعين من تقليص
النتيجه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعد قليل 9 فرنسا بطله العالم لاستعاده
فريقها ومواصله حمله الدفاع على لقبها
عندما تلاقي بولندا الطامحه في ترك بصمه
بهذا المونديال ويتعينوا على المنتخب
الفرنسي طيب صفحه الدوله الثالثه من دوري
المجموعات احنا خسرت امام تونس التركيز
على مواجهه نسور اخرى بقياده نجمها وهداف
الاستثنائي روبرت ليفاندوفسكي في المقابل
بولندا في استعاده توازنها بعد عروض
المخيبه في دوري المجموعات خاصه الخساره
امام الارجنتين في الجوله الاخيره والتي
كادت ان تطيع بها خارج البطوله
فرنسا حامله اللقب بدات مونديال قطر وهي
تخشى تكرار سيناريو 2002 والخروج من دوري
المجموعات
الديوك وقبل صافره البدايه
بغياب صاحب الكره الذهبيه كريم بنزيما
للاصابه المباراه الافتتاح امام استراليا
قالب فيها النتيجه الفرنسيون للفوز
الرباعي
مره اخرى احد ركائز المنتخب يغادر المعسكر
الاصابه وهو لوكاسيرنانديز اللقاء الثاني
امام الدنمارك شهد فوز الازرق بثنائيتك
ليان مبابي مواجهه تونس في الجوله الاخيره
اراها في هذا الشان اهم الركائز يتلقى
المنتخب الفرنسي الخساره بهدف وهبي
لم يكن سهل في مجموعه تضم الارجنتين
والسعودي والمكسيك اربعه نقاط فقط جاء على
الزملاء ليفاندوفسكي يجتازون المجموع
كواصيف للمنتخب
لقاء واحد جمع البولنديين والفرنسيين في
مسابقه الدوليه وكان ذلك في كاس العالم 82
في اسبانيا لحساب مباراه تحديد المركز
الثالث والذي شهد تفوق النسور بثلاثه
اهداف على زملائي
[موسيقى]
بكاس العالم 2014
الاسود الثلاثه منتخب انجلترا عبر الى هذا
الدور بافضليه حصيله اهداف تقاسمها مع
اسبانيا حين سجلت تسعه اهداف في ثلاث
مباريات ليواجهها اليوم الاحد منتخب
السنغال في دوري 16 على ستاد البيت في
الخور وتاهلت السنغال الى الادوار
الاقصائيه في كاس العالم للمره الثانيه
وكان ظهورها السابق في دور ال16 في 2002
عندما كان المدرب الاسيسي يحمل اشاره
قياده اسود الثيرنجا ولم تخسر انجلترا
امام اي منتخب افريقي في سبع مباريات في
كاس العالم اذ انتصرت 4 مرات وتعادلت
ثلاثا مع منتخبات من القارات السمراء
الانجليزي وصلوا الى هذه البطوله وهم
يحملون لقب اغلى منتخبا في البطوله اسماء
من الرنانه اجتمعت لاعاده الكاس الغائب عن
مهدي كره القدم منذ 56 عاما
قبل بدايه البطوله واستمرت الى قبل مواجهه
ثمن النهائي وهو الرجل الذي قاد انجلترا
الى نصف نهائي البطوله الماضيه و نهائي
نسخه الماضيه من كاس اوروبا
اما المهاجم راشفورد فيبدو انه السعاده
ثقته بنفسه مع المنتخب بعد ان كان احدا
اللاعبين الثلاثه الذين اضعوا ركله
ترجيحيه امام ايطاليا في نهائي اليورو
اصبح احد المفاتيح المهمه في خط الهجوم
الانجليزيه
السنغال بطل افريقيا تمكن من تخطي دور
المجموعات للمره الثانيه خلال ثلاث
مشاركات له فقط مدربه اليوسي سي عرف كيف
يستغل قدرات لاعبيه الذين ينشطون في اقوى
وابرز الفرق الاوروبيه المدرب السنغالي
يسعى لمعادله افضل انجازا للكره
السينغاليه في المونديال بالوصول الى ربع
النهائي وهو كان احد اعمده المنتخب كما ان
التجديد عقده قبل ايام من انطلاق المنافسه
ساعد السيسي في التركيز بشكل افضل على
تقديم اداء جيد خلال المباريات فهل تثبت
اسود التي المنتخبات الافريقيه باتت رغما
صعبا في البطوله ام ان واقعيه الانجليز
ستنهي المغامره السنغاليه
[موسيقى]
منذ المباراه الاولى قدم اجويرو الرد
الافضل على كل ما مر به لقد قدم اداء
مذهلا في المباريات الثلاث التي خاضها حتى
الان وعلينا مواصله البناء لعبت الى جواره
في العديد من المباراه الدوليه وعشنا معا
العديد من اللحظات ولا يستحق ما مر به مع
ناديه
المهمه يوم الجمعه
والارشادات اللازمه وما علينا القيام به
ناموا ان يكون متواجدا في الملعب يوم
المباراه وان يقود الفريق من ارض الملعب
هدفنا هو الصعود وانا متاكد ان اللاعبين
سيكونوا جاهزين ومستعدين ستكون مواجهه
صعبه لكن علينا ان نحافظ على الهدوء
كشفت تيتي مدرب البرازيل الاحد ان نيمار
سيشارك مع المنتخب البرازيلي في مباراه
دوري 16 لكاس العالم لكره القدم امام
كوريا الجنوبيه يوم غدا الاثنين وتلقى
المدافع سؤال في مؤتمر الصحفي بشان
امكانيه مشاركه نيمار في المباراه
بالايجاب وخاض نيمار سباق مع زمن حتى يكون
جاهزا عقب اصابه في الكاحل امام صربيا في
اولى مباريات المجموعه السابعه
هذه كاتب روز اخبار الرياضه ونعود الان
الى الزميله رشا نبيل لاستكمال النشره
[موسيقى]
جيد للغايه عاده ثلاثه رواد فضاء صينيين
بعد اتمام مهمه استمرت سته اشهر في الفضاء
وهبط الوضع ثلاثه في موقع في شمال الصين
بعد ان سلموا مقاليد السيطره على محطه
الفضاء الصينيه ليكمل اول دوره النطاقم في
المدارس